you recommended a product to me mycopole because of high mycotoxid levels. What would you
recommend for docine? Okay, so your levels of myrophilinic acid were really high if I remember.
So they were real high, but you could be excreted a lot. So when we talked about that, so maybe that's
why they were high because you're just you're doing a good job of dumping them. So one or two per day,
I mean, typically I recommend one per day, but if you want to see if you could pull faster,
you could go with two a day if you are supporting all the other
stages of detoxification. So if you're supporting, if you're having a good model with that's phase
six of detoxification, if you're if you feel like your liver is doing well, you're not having
pain on your right side and you know, make sure you're you're doing other things like coffee
enemies and putting hot packs over your liver, castor hot packs over your liver to support that.
If you're doing those things that you can certainly take more key lady binding type supplements,
but if you're like constipated a lot, then you got to go slower and you should not be taking more
than one a day if that.